I'm crazy about what I can touch and what I can seek I don't even know what fate is, my eyes are full of pain But one day you will realize that behind your back There are wings to aim for the distant future That's what I believe A cruel angel's reincarnation
Be a
legend, young boy Be a legend,
young boy
Be a legend Even if the blue wind knocks on the door of my heart You are just staring at me and smiling
少年よ 神話になれ!
残酷な天使のように 少年よ 神話になれ!
風が今 群れのドアを叩いても 私だけを ただ見つめて 微笑んで
I took, I meant, I took every, I, okay, not every medication possible, like, oh my god, I just know, oh my god, please, sorry, I'm gonna close my door so my humidifier can work perfectly fine.
Alright, I got my Buckley's, uh, meds in, I got my tea, my hot tea, I did Manuka honey, and then I also did the, the Chinese black herbal medicine.
Okay, we're okay, we're not okay, but we're okay.
But today is a very special stream because today we are sponsored by Nikkei again, Nikkei Goddess of Victory, for their very special promotion, the Evangelion promotion.
Their second one, by the way, this is their second collaboration with EVA, I'm so sorry if I'm pronouncing Evangelion wrong.
Um, um, is it bad to say I've never watched or, I know the references, I know every reference is there, I never, I never watched or read, I guess you can't read it because it was a, it was a show slash anime, but I have seen all the GIFs and all the references and everything,
does that count?
I know, congratulate, all the memes, I know all the memes, so like, I know all the memes, I know who's the best girl, I know who's the worst girl, I know, I know all the, I, I know, um, I know the, the, the end, the end couple, um, and everything, so like,
I know all the ones that mattered, you know?
Um, and then I know like, that white haired dude, that's like, I want you Shinji, like, I have no other context other than the fact that this guy really wants Shinji, that's all, that's all I know.
I know the gay part.
Anyway, huge shout out and thank you to Nikkei for sponsoring me, it's always a great pleasure to, um, uh, yeah, he said, he said the best girl already, so, uh, huge shout out for sponsoring me again, uh, for another Nikkei stream, it's always a fun time checking out Nikkei ever so often,
so I'm really excited to check it out.
Uh, before we begin, um, we have several videos, uh, that they want me to look at to blindly react to, cause like I said, I went in blind, so I don't really know what's actually, what the new collab is gonna be, like, what actually is happening in the new collab other than,
like, the basic, like, structure of everything.
Um, I don't know what the, uh, the gameplay of the new collab is gonna be, because they wanted me to check out the new arcade mode and everything, so it's gonna be really fun seeing what it is and seeing the trailer and everything.
But, oh my god, you can see my voice deteriorating as we go along.
Um, but, if you wanna support the stream, if you wanna support the game, please feel free to check the link below in the description or pinned in the chat, uh, so yeah, it really helps support the stream, it really helps support, uh, the game as well,
and provides me more opportunities for sponsors.
Yeah, in real time, I'm, like, sounding more and more like a teenage boy.
I think if I talk in this, in this, like, voice, um, in game, people will actually think I'm a guy.
Like...
Mmm.
So yeah, let's check out the, um, let's check out the trailers for the new collaboration!
I hope it's not too loud.
I have, like, three videos to check out, so we'll see here.
Um, where did I put it?
I'm such a professional.
Is this right?
Whoa.
Like I said, this is actually their, um, second collaboration with them.
So, their new, um, Asuka, Rei, and, um, uh, I forgot the third girl.
Mari!
Sorry, I don't know if anyone ever remembers the third girl.
Oh, is it too loud?
Don't worry, I'll turn it down.
Um, anyway, um, this is actually the, they have actually released a skins, not skins, characters of them already in the first collab, but the second collab is, like, a different version of them.
Oh, that's the new arcade mode, apparently.
It's like, it's like, um, oh, what is it called?
Like those, oh my god, we all know what it's called, but I can't say it.
It's like HOTO.
It's like, bullet hell.
It's, oh my god, it's bullet hell.
And apparently, they come with free skins, too.
Yeah, they're, like, alternate versions of themselves.
Um, I don't know, apparently she's called Asuka Willy.
I don't know what the Willy stands for.
Um, but, um, they also come with free skins, apparently.
Uh, so yeah, it's like bullet hell, uh, for the new arcade.
Alright, so that's trailer number one.
Trailer number... is that trailer number two?
Wait, what trailer did I place?
Official collaboration.
Oh, okay, trailer number two.
Oh my god,
get in the robot.
There's the robots.
Wait, he has a tail?
Okay, you can tell my knowledge of Evangelion.
I'm like, he has a tail?
That looks cool, though.
I mean, it looks really insane.
Like, the amount of effort put into this.
Sure, a power cord.
That's what all classic furries say.
That's what they all say, a power cord.
Alright, well, that's where I am.
Alright, and then finally, the final trailer.
The official... this one.
Oh, I'm definitely gonna get demonetized, though.
Oh my god.
I already knew I was gonna get paid, get demonetized.
All things are equal.
I already played this song, like, five or six times.
It's alright.
But yeah, anyway.
So, starting today, I believe.
It started either today or, like, technically it started yesterday, because the maintenance was yesterday.
This collaboration with EVA started, and I believe it... oh my gosh.
It's called Second... so they have a new event called Second Quest.
And basically, throughout the weeks, you'll be able to basically get, you know, Rei, Asuka, and the other girl, Marie.
I'm sorry.
They all have names, but we all know which girl has a high... which girl is more important than the other girl.
And so throughout the weeks, you'll be able to be able to pull... you'll be able to pull various girls of them, and they are gonna be the alternate versions of... because, like, in the first collab, they also had them, and you can also re-pull for them for this collab as well.
You mean Kaoru, right?
But for this one, you can pull alternate versions of them, and they also come with apparently free skins as well as specific skins for this collab, so that'll be very interesting.
But they have a new collaboration story, which is the Second Quest, and they have the, you know, Asuka... oh, they also have Sakura!
Sorry, I forgot the other girl, Sakura.
I think it's that girl, the girl on the far right.
That is so... okay, that is so messed up.
Sakura replaced Mari.
That's so messed up!
I just noticed, I just noticed, I was like, who's the third?
I don't know, there's Sakura though.
So yeah, I believe Sakura is for free at the moment, right?
They did Mari!
I was like, wait, shouldn't it be adding Mari here?
But then I noticed, I just noticed Sakura is right here, so...
Alright, it's alright.
You'll eventually get Mari?
Where's Mari?
But yes, apparently Sakura is actually an SR character, so she'll be a free unit.
Anyway, this girl is free, by the way.
But yes, there's brand new skins, limited edition dress skins, and they'll have new animations, new voice lines, there's also a new... oh my god, my voice cracked!
There's a new mini-game, which is a bullet hell, and the event will last February 20th to March 12th.
So, there's plenty of time, but I mean, the earlier you're... I'm sorry, I'm going through puberty right now!
Sorry!
Oh my god, oh my god, I'm actually going through puberty in real time!
It's actually crazy!
Okay, let's go in.
What?
My own... oh my god, I never forgot about you, sister.
Oh yes, there's a new character that we can do.
Hello, Rapunzel.
I'll never forget about... okay, by the way, I re-logged in today, and then like, I didn't know this, but like, they give you like, they scold you.
They'll be like, where are you?
And then like, your girls are like, super angry with you, and are like, where did you go?
We missed you so much!
In the beginning, if you don't log in after a while, they literally are like, where did you go?
I was scared, and I was so scared!
Okay, let's see, turn the music down.
Okay, I hope this is better.
Alright, so I'm back with Milk Rapunzel.
Oh my god, so much... her eyes are up here, guys.
Guys, this is... guys, she is literally wearing a cross, guys.
No... there's no... no sinful thoughts, guys.
Guys, she's literally wearing a cross.
There's no confessions today, everybody.
There's no... there's no confessions today.
Alright, so... let's check out what you can pull.
She's... she's not a sinner!
She's not a sinner, how dare you?
Look at all... she has like, one, two, three, four crosses.
How can you sin with all those crosses?
With the power of Christ, her eyes are up here.
Alright, anyway, I think guys, like you guys said, there's the second quest, the other story.
I know for the... okay, okay.
Let's go... okay, so... this is the new recruitment you can get, which is... Willi.
I'll just call her Willi.
Her full name is Asuka.
The pilot of... due to the curse of Eva, her physical appearance has remained perpetually at 14 years of age.
I'll call her my girl, Willi.
The E is silent?
What, is it Will?
Alright, Will.
Alright, Willi.
I didn't get her... I don't have enough, so I hope I get her first try, I really do.
But yeah, you can get her limited, like right now, basically.
And then, if you didn't have her in the first collab, you can try and get her now.
Um, Vil Eye.
Wait, her name is Vil Eye?
Sorry.
Why would you name it Willi?
Just makes me wanna call you Willi, Free Willi.
Free Willi.
Alright.
Alright, I think I can get her first try.
Alright, drumroll.
Boooom.
Alright, here we go.
I didn't get her.
Wait, did I got her?
I don't think so.
It was all red.
I only have like- I can try- I can have seven tries.
No, it's okay.
I wanna know who are these people?
I feel like- Oh my god, I always get you.
I don't want you, Neon!
I never want you!
I did!
I will sell you if I could.
Okay.
Okay, give me a sec.
Okay, I- Alright, give me a sec, guys.
Let me fix my volume.
What did I say?
Music volume is at 26 now.
In-game- In-game can be like 2-3.
Voice can be down a bit as well.
Alright, here we go.
One by one.
Can't be that bad.
This makes it more exciting, guys.
This makes it so much more exciting doing it one by one.
They're half a person.
Alright, recruit again.
This makes it so exciting, guys.
Wait, was that it?
Wait, it glowed a little.
What if- Okay, nevermind.
Okay, but what if like- Can I do recruit ten and then use up all five?
Wait, cause five and a thousand- Oh!
Oh, I can just use my gems!
Wait, no, I can just use my gems.
What the hell?
I can just do that.
Oh, wait, is that- What's my luck?
What's- What's- What happened?
What happened to my luck?
Why isn't Deon?!
Ever since- Ever since Cookie Run has all been downhill, it's ever since-
Oh my god.
I don't understand!
I used to be so lucky!
What happened to me?
There's no way.
This is literally my last roll.
Please.
She's sort of like Asuka.
Like, if you like, squint your eyes really, really hard...
And like, change your colors to red...
She's... She's sort of like her.
Oh, and I get her again?
Oh, you treat me so well.
Oh, okay.
I have three pulls.
Guys, okay.
Music down a little bit.
SFX down by a little bit more.
And then voice is fine.
Alright, cool.
Alright.
Oh, they just gave me another 10?
Oh, thank you.
I was- I don't know what to do.
Oh my god, ETHAN!
Why do you do this to me?
What do you mean?
What is my mal- No, I already claimed everything.
Guys, you liars.
You baited me.
I thought I already claimed all my mail.
Guys, I claimed my mail before I started the stream.
What?
I was- Why did you bait me?
You liars.
I claimed it before the stream.
Wait, what's the promo codes?
Guys, it was in my briefing.
What's the promo code?
Type the codes.
I don't know how to use- Type the codes, guys.
Guys, how do I- Okay, okay.
What are the codes?
The promo codes.
What is it called?
What are they called?
Oh, they're expired.
Oh, that's why it wasn't in the briefing.
That's why.
Oh my god.
It's okay, we have two more.
We have two more, guys.
Surely, these two rows will be it.
Oh my god, is this real?
Is this a real code?
Okay, I'm copying this just in case.
Maybe.
Maybe we're just that lucky.
Okay, maybe we're not.
Okay, where do we put the codes?
Where do we put the codes?
Where is it?
It's only 100 gems?
What am I gonna do with 100 gems?
Get out of my way!
What am I gonna do with 100 gems, guys?
Oh, scroll down.
And there she is.
The innocent maid.
What?
Where?
CD key portal?
Oh, okay.
Tap to enter.
Wait, actually, I don't trust you guys, so I'm gonna- Alright, I hid it.
CD key.
Redeem now.
Oh my god, I got it.
I got the X whatever whatever number.
Okay, you guys are so smart.
What did I redeem?
What did I even redeem?
I don't even know.
I don't even know what I redeemed.
Okay, oh, and that one too?
Okay, the 2N.
Okay, don't worry, I got you guys.
I got you guys.
I can't believe it.
I don't even get Asuka.
Oh my god.
It's been like ever since that fateful day.
Ever since I- Guys, remember how lucky I was and- Oh, the code has reached its maximum usage.
Guys, who used up all the codes?
Guys, you had to use it after my stream.
Oh, wait.
Oh, it's right here.
Okay, lame.
Alright, nice.
100 gems, I can't- I don't know if I can actually do anything with it.
Alright, guys.
Okay.
Alright, here we go.
We have one more roll.
Could this be it?
Could this be the roll of the century?
Right here?
Right now?
Where it just naturally becomes Asuka?
Okay, but like- Okay, think of it this way, guys.
If I do- Guys, technically, it can be Asuka.
Guys, technically, she can be Asuka.
Watch this, guys.
Watch this.
Where's red?
Okay, that looks like red.
And then if I- If I add it all the way-
Wait, okay.
Okay, technically- Technically, it's- Oh my god, we did it!
We did it, guys!
We got Asuka!
Oh my god!
Oh my god, we did it, everyone!
We got her!
It's her!
Guys, we got Asuka!
Oh my god, we got Willy!
We did it, everyone!
We got Willy!
I'm so happy!
We did it!
I don't have enough gems!
What happened to me?
I used to be so lucky!
What happened?
Guys, I used to be so good at this!
What happened to me?
Not anymore.
No!
I can't even like- Oh my god, I just claimed it.
Nice.
Free stuff.
At least I'll get- Okay, by the way, you can go to her passion casino and get free stuff.
And then there's- Oh yeah, that's her- That's the free- Oh wait, no.
Okay, and then there's- Which one was it?
There was another free stuff right here.
Oh, the secret box?
What's the secret box?
Oh, there's a free gacha?
Oh wait, is this a- That's for her skin, right?
Bad start to the- Oh, it's been a bad start for a long time.
Yabby, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
It's okay.
At least- At least I have free stuff.
Thank you for the aka soup, but thank you, thank you.
I have a soup, but that's the same color.
Asuka, please use it to restore your luck.
Oh my god, you don't- Oh my god, what happened?
What happened, everyone?
Why can't I claim you?
Okay, I claimed it, okay.
Alright, at least we got that.
And then we got another free gacha, let's go.
Like, girls, just thank you for the aka soup, but at least- At least free stuff more.
At least, if I absorbed all your bad luck, at least by me doing all the bad gacha spins, I have absorbed all your bad luck.
So you can get Asuka with my download link.
Download the game right now with the link in my description and the link pin.
I can't believe I didn't get Asuka.
I can't believe it.
Oh my god, what happened to me?
What happened?
I'm sorry, I'm just a little sad.
I'm just- I can't believe it.
I used to be the luckiest- I used to be the luckiest VTuber in gacha.
I was so lucky.
What happened to me?
What happened?
GachaFuzzHellDance, oh my god, HellDance!
Thank you for your very first aka soup, but it's an aka, aka, aka.
Oh my god.
Oh my- Okay, you know what?
I never do this, but because you literally just donated $500, because I'm already- You know, it's a sponsored, I'm literally paid to play this game right now, but because you were so nice, I will buy 10 rolls.
Wait, how much is 10 rolls?
I might just buy one roll.
I don't know, I've never paid for a gacha before.
How much is- Okay, how much is 3,000 gems?
Oh my god, that's $54?
Jesus Christ.
Uh...
Give me a sec, I need to think about this.
Give me a sec, I need to think about this a little bit.
Oh wait, there's free stuff right here.
By the way, I just found out.
The setup package, they had free gems right here, which was nice.
And then- Oh wait, there's a free- Oh my god, look at all these free stuff.
Oh my god, thank you.
Oh, and then there's- Oh my god, I get another roll!
I have another roll, guys!
Wait, do I get free stuff here?
No.
What about here?
Oh my god.
Five.
Okay, $30.
I kept 10 rolls and $30.
Alright, just because you gave me- Okay, I didn't have 10 rolls with my first purchase.
This is a very rare Doki Bird moment right there.
Very rare!
I would- Not the gems?
Wait, what?
Which one do I buy?
Wait.
Okay, wait, which one do I buy?
Wait, bundle is- Guys, I'm not familiar with this.
Wait, what does that even mean?
What the fuck is a bundle?
Guys, I don't understand the context of this.
What do you mean by bundle?
You mean these?
First icon, second package?
Oh, which one?
This one?
Wait, is that it?
The $20 one?
Is that one?
The special recruit pack?
Is that it?
Oh my god.
Okay, there we go.
Alright, that's a good investment.
$20 for $500?
I feel like that's a good deal.
That's such a good deal right there.
Oh my god, what happened to me?
Is this how people get into- I don't understand.
I've always been so lucky.
Like, what happened to me?
Like, what happened?
I've never been so unlucky before.
What the fuck happened to me?
What?
I don't understand.
I've never felt this way before.
Things have been so good to me, but now nothing.
Oh my god.
I don't like- I don't like this.
I haven't had any crisis right now.
I'm going through some crisis.
I'm going through some stuff right now.
Okay.
It's okay.
It's okay, guys.
Okay.
We don't get it.
We just don't get it.
It was just never meant to be.
It was just- It was just never meant to be.
It begins.
Oh man, thank you.
Thank you.
Oh my god.
There's no way.
Is that it?
What?
Oh my god.
Oh my god, is that it?
Oh my god, is my hell over?
Oh my god.
Who are you?
Guys.
Guys, oh my god.
Guys, oh my god, it's Asuka.
Oh my god, it's Asuka.
Look at her.
Oh my god.
Willy.
Willy, you're home, Willy.
You're home.
It's okay, we have one more chance.
We have one more chance.
She's good, but she's not Asuka.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, we have one more.
We have one more.
Oh my god, it's Asuka too.
Okay, this has to be her.
This has to be her, right?
No!
Oh my god, she has red too.
It's Asuka 3!
No way!
Are you fucking serious?
Oh my god.
It's okay, we still have enough.
We still have enough for another pull up.
We still have enough for another- oh, and we didn't get it.
We didn't even get it.
What's the point?
I don't want to see your freaking faces again.
You didn't get- you actually got pretty rare, very strong characters, so you still got a one.
Guys, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
We have one more pull, guys.
We have one more pull.
This is gonna be it.
It would be crazy if I get her right here, right now.
Oh my god, it'd be so goddamn crazy I didn't get her.
It would've been so crazy though.
Oh my god.
Okay, what else can I say?
But guys, but guys, I got- where's Asuka too?
Where is she?
Guys, but like...
She's technically Asuka if I- if I look hard enough.
Oh my god, you're so beautiful, Asuka.
Asuka Willia, you're so- you're so beautiful.
You're so beautiful, blue- Asuka Willia.
You're literally her.
She's literally her, guys.
Oh, what am I looking at?
Alright, view mode.
Oh my god.
Whoa, Asuka.
Asuka, whoa.
That's so beautiful.
You're so beautiful.
Oh my god.
Okay, what is this like?
How do I shoot with her?
Oh my god, what kind of gun is that?
Am I even aiming with this gun?
Guys, I'm talking about the gun, guys.
Oh, that's cute.
That's actually so cute.
How do you even aim?
It just aims for you.
If it helps, I got her.
How does that help?
You still got- I mean, I got her too, guys.
I also got- you know what?
I'm gonna level her up.
I don't give you everything.
That's right.
I'll give you everything.
Everything I own, you can have it.
I don't care.
You can have it all.
My Asuka.
My lovely Asuka.
You can have it all.
I don't care.
Okay, cube.
What's the cube?
Do I have anything?
Oh, thank you.
You're so beautiful.
Alright, nice.
Alright, she- I love her already.
Guys, it's okay.
Guys, did you guys see that?
I can't believe I got Asuka.
Guys, I can't- when did I level her up to level 40?
Oh my god, just realized she's level- Cinderella's level 40.
Oh my god.
What is my lineup?
It's been a while since I looked at this.
Okay, we're putting- alright, Milk, you're getting out of here.
Wait.
Who do I want to change, actually?
Yeah, that was- yeah, Pastoki was going crazy.
Pastoki was going crazy with Cinderella.
Change Milk?
Okay, Milk.
Goodbye, Milk.
We don't need you.
You're not as important anymore.
Alright, nice.
Alright, now we have our level 40 Cinderella.
And our level 17 Modernio.
Alright, now that we pulled Asuka, Willy version, it's time to play the new Bullet Hell.
Oh, I need a burst one.
Oh, I need Milk?
Okay, then who do I get rid of?
Wait, who do I get rid of then?
Guys...
Privacy?
Alright, goodbye, Privacy.
We're getting doxxed.
Oh, we don't need Klee?
Alright, goodbye, Klee.
Go back to school, I guess.
Oh wait, it's called Privity.
I thought that name was Privacy.
I thought their name was Privacy for a sec.
Alright, we don't need cheerleaders.
There we go.
Is that good?
I should be good now.
Alright, nice.
Alright, arcade time.
Where is it?
Oh, for the king?
I think it's called the Red Sea?
Wait, what's this?
What's my welcome back?
Oh, I forgot to claim my other thing.
Wait, is there another one?
Welcome back pass?
I'll claim my hearts.
And then, is there anything else?
Oh, I can claim this.
Oh, it's in the event.
Okay.
Where is it?
It's called...
The event is called Red Sea Scout.
Red Sea Scout, where are you?
Red Sea Scout.
It's the second quest.
We got to play the event first.
I'll play the second quest first.
Guys, who's the swan that's getting sponsored, right?
BB.
Thank you, chat, for helping me.
Oh, the ocean.
Guys, look.
We're on the sea.
We're back on the Atmire again.
Am I dreaming?
Both of you, calm down.
Gatekeeper could pop up anywhere.
Summit's on a D-Wave detector?
No.
Whoa!
Captain.
No nominees detected so far.
What's with Summit this time?
I've got a bad feeling.
Can't even imagine Summit stuffed an ocean this time.
Well, flight capabilities, whatever it is, will just sink, right?
Maybe a giant?
Support in a moment.
Sorry, I can't do voices right now, so they are going to sound like a 14-year-old boy.
We established contact with the advance team.
They report no anomalies around the destination.
Bang!
So sexy, am I right?
Violent tremor erupts in the distance.
What?
What was that noise?
Commander, 3 o'clock.
Sorry.
Oh my god.
I looked in the distance.
Rappi is pointing.
With a humanoid weapon, a giant looms in the distance.
Watch out!
Incoming waves!
Everyone, grab something!
The sea heaves violently as another tremor rocks the ship.
Wait, look at that.
Are there more of them now?
Hearing Ana's words, I looked again towards the giant.
Oh no.
Next to the first giant, two more giants with similar appearances have emerged.
Two giants start to strike the first one that appeared.
Signal confirmed.
D-Wave detected from two new newcomers.
So they are gatekeepers doing...
Bang!
A deafening sound echoes through the world.
Support it!
Okay, wait.
I can make it sound so sexy.
Commander, get down!
Rappi shields and his helm braces against the aft.
Don't you know?
Bang!
A massive shot wave slams into us.
Rappi helm!
Are you alright?
I'm fine, but help!
Um...
Oh, it's no big deal.
Quit pushing yourself, you're hurt.
What's happening?
The ocean's turning red!
I looked towards where Ana's is pointing.
My day is ruined!
The ocean...
It's red?
It's not just the ocean.
The sky, too!
What about the giants?
There's only one left, but...
It's not moving anymore!
Oh my God, wait, she's wet!
Oh my God, look at the water effects, ew!
Where did the other two go?
The remaining giant's outline is flickering, like a shadow.
We need a closer inspection.
I'm afraid it's not possible.
The admirer collided with a cluster in the blast.
Oh my God, Asuka!
She's red!
Asuka, is that you?
We need to assess the damage first.
Are you sure you're okay?
I'm fine.
Don't push or check if you're injured and keep an eye on your surroundings.
I'll shift you, we can request backup.
Oh my God, Asuka's four at five!
Got it.
Understood.
There's so many Asukas!
There's so many!
These three figures are observing the chaos.
It's not over yet!
Call the Asuka!
Oh, nice!
There's blue Asuka!
I'm sorry, I'm going crazy right now.
Everywhere I look, I see her.
Alright.
Wendy, there's something contaminated.
Can I go here?
Wait, what's this?
Oh, coming soon.
Okay, this is a future event.
I gotta progress though.
Hold this for a second.
Oh, a danger zone.
Oh wait, we should get the story, right?
Oh wait, there's login stamps!
There might be bonuses!
Oh my God, yes!
Can I claim all?
Okay, we got two tickets, guys.
What's the danger zone, guys?
Guys, what's the danger zone?
Danger zone!
More gambling!
What's the danger zone for?
Sounds so safe.
Alright, we gotta do five stages of story one.
Yes, you should.
Chapter one.
Alright, enter.
Alright, let's go.
Wait, who is like...
Wait, who do I...
Who do I have?
Who cares about these people?
Who are her...
Who are these three, right?
And then we got rid of Clay and put Novel here.
Was it all these?
Yeah, we don't need these guys.
Plus 20%?
Who matters?
What, really?
We don't care about them.
They're not... they're SR.
Guys, they're SR.
Novel, we're throwing you away.
Wait.
I'll throw you away for her.
Oh, they'll give a bonus to rewards?
Okay.
I'll get rid of...
Wait, we need milk, right?
I'll get rid of you, Privatey, and then I'll put you in here.
And then...
Yeah, that should be good.
The number higher more pulls?
Wait.
Okay.
Bonus is best choice?
Okay, you can change milk for Neon.
Wait, for Neon.
Alright.
We'll put Cinderella.
And we'll put Cinderella and Modernia.
Yeah.
That's fine.
That should be fine, right?
That should be good.
My two characters can carry these guys.
I believe.
I literally have a level 40 Cinderella.
If she dies, they're hopeless.
Wait,
I should do auto.
I need to blow my nose.
Sorry, I'm not reading this while I blow my nose.
Alright.
Thank you.
That's correct.
Two of their signals have disappeared, leaving only one remaining.
It seems the green one took down the other two.
But...
Did it take down the other two just to survive?
A dangerous entity indeed.
At this point, it's difficult to observe or identify the remaining giant, so the central government has officially decided to name it Phantom.
We'll also be keeping an eye on this Phantom from now on.
Please continue searching for a way to counter it.
I have a question.
Aside from the Phantom and Giant, has any other D-Wave been detected?
If you're referring to humans summoned by the D-Wave like last time...
I heard that just moments ago, three human-shaped biological signals emitting D-Waves were detected.
Oh, you mean like...
Asuka, Willi...
Rei...
And Sakura?
Because Marie doesn't exist.
Sorry.
Sorry, Marie.
Sakura took your spot.
I'd like you to verify this as well.
So they're here again.
Yeah, this is not the first time.
This is not their first time.
She got benched.
I'll be counting on you!
Commander, have you finished communicating with the ARK?
Yes, I have finished speaking with the Deputy Chief.
It seems there are humans emitting D-Wave again.
Asuka, Asuka, and Asuka?
True, as expected.
First, let's secure the area.
Check Helm's condition and begin the search.
It's important!
There's no need to worry about me!
The Admirer and Agnes aren't so fragile.
Maintenance will be finished soon.
Just trust me and start the search first.
Are you really okay?
Yes, just as we trust your judgment, I want you to trust us too.
Got it.
Rappi, prepare for the search.
Mast and Anchor, stay here and keep watch around the area with Helm.
Roger.
Got it.
Ahoy!
Oh my god, what the hell is that?
Is that a parrot?
Oh my god, is that parrot okay?
A moment later.
Commander, we're about to enter the area where the human D-Wave was detected.
Agnes and Neon, stay in formation.
Keep an eye on the front.
Okay.
Oh!
Literally little Asuka!
I didn't expect to see Asuka right away.
You...
The real one!
I didn't think you existed!
Oh my god, you're real!
I thought you were!
What's going on?
Why are you here?
The legend!
She's real!
How can you be here?
Weren't you supposed to have returned to your original world after the massive object suppression operation?
Did Gatekeeper summon you here again?
Yes.
Wait, look at her eyes.
You mean her singular eye?
What happened to your eyes?
Do you know me?
We've been through so much together.
Oh my god, it's the girl!
Of course I know that girl too!
She's right in front of me, isn't she?
Oh no way!
This seems a bit different.
What's she doing?
What luck!
Wait, you said who from where?
You know special duty lieutenant colonel?
Then you shouldn't approach that person casually.
What?
Did you have a fight?
Aren't you both from Nerve?
Why the hostility?
No, we belong to Willy!
Nerve is our enemy.
Wait, so Asuka and Rion are on the opposing sides now?
Even becoming enemies?
Why do I get the feeling they don't remember us?
Looks like we all have things to clarify.
Sakura, selling scores with Nerve isn't a priority now.
Shouldn't we focus on gathering intel from them first?
I agree.
Yeah, these are alternate universe versions of them.
I sound like Bobby Hill right now.
I can feel like Bobby Hill right now.
We brave Asuka and the others on the previous operation against Massive Object.
The Iraq was shocked they shared details about their world.
This is our first time in this world, yet you know so much about us.
Honestly, it's suspicious, but fine.
We'll cooperate, just don't get in our way.
The Special Duty Lieutenant currently mentioned resembles someone from our past.
Ah, pardon my manners, I'm Sakura Suzuhara, Willy's medical officer.
Just call me Sakura.
I think I get it now.
Time flows differently here compared to their world.
Unbelievable.
Our timeline barely moved, but theirs jumped years ahead.
A long time has passed in Asuka's world, and so much has happened.
Where is Marie?
She got benched.
I said it as a joke, but apparently she did.
Their relationship with Ray changed.
Plus, they forgot about us.
That makes me kinda sad.
At least they're willing to team up.
Let's get to the point.
To resolve all of this, we must combat a city called Gatekeeper, correct?
Yes.
To return home, you must awaken Gatekeeper and fight whatever manifests like last time.
The previous massive object had an anti-field blocking our attacks, but objects you touch leave D-Wave resonance.
Weaponizing that resonance can break the field.
So we should be fighting in a similar way this time as well.
Got it.
Beat Gatekeeper to go home.
Enough talk.
Let's make a plan.
We'll hash out details on the move.
Alright, let's go.
We're gaming.
Someone's like, she's 30.
She's 26.
She's 30.
How old?
It's alright, she's old.
Okay, I don't wanna play as you.
I wanna play as... not you.
Okay, there we go.
An important person.
A level 40.
Level 40, please.
There we go.
As long as you're level 40, that's all that matters.
Cinderella's got this.
Wait, what did I do?
Oh my god.
Alright, easy.
Oh, that's fast.
Easy.
That's right.
The girl in the black plaguesuit crushes the ruptured wreckage.
Asuka carried.
You're right, my Asuka carried.
One thing confuses me.
That Rei.
She's not the one we know, is she?
That's right.
She's from an early lot.
Ayanami series.
I love her pose.
Her pose is very deliberate.
A blank state, fresh off the assembly line.
An initial lot, fresh off the assembly line, you say?
What is this?
Rapture remains.
They're your enemies?
Yes.
We eliminate them.
Tentative name.
To be decided.
You'll be carrying them a lot from now on, but don't worry.
We'll be here with you.
I can't agree with that.
Even if you've had formal training and are different from ordinary Leland, you won't be able to defeat that phantom with your previous methods.
Hey, Asuka!
You keep calling us Leland.
What's a Leland?
It means humans.
We're Nikes, not humans.
What?
Are you crazy?
Accept the commander.
We're Nikes, humanoid weapons designed for fighting ruptures.
That sounds familiar.
Familiar?
How?
This world's messed up too, huh?
Commander!
Without the combat experience from the past, should rupture training drills be conducted first?
We should head back to the Ark for...
Skip it.
No training.
That thing took my new unit too.
I'll never forgive it.
This fight's not what you think.
It's Evangelion versus Evange...
Gillion.
Oh, Gillion.
Sorry, I realized I said...
Everything just clicked.
I was like, oh, it's Evangelion.
Everything just clicked in my head.
I was like, oh shit, I've been pronouncing it wrong this entire time.
Oh no, my power's too weak.
Okay, she's too weak.
I might have to get rid of you and put in...
Private-y.
Wait, who am I getting rid of?
Okay, wait.
Is my power level okay?
Oh no, my power level is still...
Literally shit.
Alright, whatever.
Whatever, I'll put you back in.
It's fine.
Okay, I believe you guys.
I'm mini before taking.
Like, I just processed it.
It was like, oh wait.
I've been pronouncing it wrong this entire time.
Alright, don't worry.
I'm gonna use my other Asuka.
Asuka tool.
Don't worry, Asuka tool.
I'm ready for you.
Alright, now I got board, so I'm gonna use my other one.
Okay, nice.
I don't need to use anything yet.
I'm waiting till... Alright, there we go.
Evangelion.
Connor, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Nice.
Alright, nice.
We gotta get to five, right?
If we get to five...
Five, we unlock the other thing.
We return to the shore to reach the Admire.
Asuka.
Huh?
Remember anything before arriving here?
No, I was in Alina Village.
And then, I woke up here.
I was aboard the Wonder.
Then suddenly, Hero of Ray.
And then we found that thing.
The thing you called Phantom.
That thing's no joke.
If it's different from what you knew, could it be modified like a Rupture?
You think it's Rupture's hybrid?
You can remove the hub.
Oh, sorry.
Is this better?
Do you wanna see their legs?
I see no wonder it doesn't have an operator.
It fused with Rupture.
Ever since I arrived in this world... Sorry, you want me to help you guys?
Ever since I arrived in this world, I felt that thing was dangerous.
What happened?
I saw it attack a Nika Nika near coast.
So, I had to pilot my Eva to save her.
Wait, you mean those giant things fighting the Phantoms?
No, it's too much.
Yeah, you saw them?
Me and that early lot were piloting Evas.
We're Evangelion.
Sorry, my head.
We're Evangelion pilots.
So, those were you?
Three giant robots?
This is peak firepower.
Whatever.
At least the Evas got dragged here too.
You rode inside them?
Yeah, I fought the Phantom.
Until it froze mid-battle.
Maybe prepping?
It's prepping for another attack.
Don't know.
I don't even have the specifics either.
But judging by its current look, it might be in an unstable state right now.
Thank you for the superchat.
You mean Asuka?
The third?
Based on what Asuka said, the compact logs we have against Gatekeeper so far...
Gatekeeper was planning to use the Phantom to attack us.
But due to attacks from the...
It's like I see someone wearing any form of red.
Asuka?
If even the sky... Oh my god, Sky Asuka?
I think this friend is far greater than the previous massive object.
If something like that gets fully summoned...
Yeah, it could cause massive damage to the Ark.
We have to stop the Phantom from being fully summoned.
Wait, was that impact just now also from Gatekeeper summoning?
That's insane.
Alright.
It's time to kill again.
Oh, you're all Asuka.
Why am I always you?
I don't care about you!
Alright.
Pew!
Pew, pew, pew, pew, pew.
Damn, look at me go.
My level 14.
Okay, don't worry.
Pew, pew, pew, pew, pew, pew, pew, pew.
Okay.
Nice.
Nice, alright.
And then...
We'll just use my Cinderella attack.
Oh my god, nice.
Oh wait, everybody's dead.
Wait.
Oh, that's awkward.
Um, guys?
How... how are they all dead, guys?
How are they all...
Whoa, that's awkward.
I'm reloading.
That's a little awkward.
I did not expect them to be all dead.
Dead already?
So...
Okay.
Oh, it's just me?
Okay, guys.
I think...
Maybe they have a lot of power levels.
Just maybe.
Just... oh.
Oh, I'll just wait until it's over.
Oh, I think we're dead.
Okay,
I guess I'll level up Mirdania.
I don't know who to level up.
Wait, I don't have enough.
Wait, can I limit break Cinderella?
Can I limit break you?
Oh, I can't.
Oh.
Wait, no.
Oh, you actually write Asuka.
I meant Asuka.
Oh, no.
Oh, can I even... oh.
Oh, wait, I can limit break her.
Okay, nice.
Yay!
Wait, I can upgrade her with her own body parts.
Is that good?
Go to base and level sync?
Oh.
Oh, I level sync.
Where's my base?
Guys, I'm a little confused.
What?
I don't have base.
Guys, no.
It's locked.
I have never finished 2.12.
No!
Guys, I can't open the boxes.
Guys, which box do I open?
Guys.
Which box can I open?
Do I open it all?
Okay.
Do I open these?
All of them?
Okay.
Nice.
Alright.
I'm opening them all.
I don't know.
What are these?
Open it all.
I don't know what you are.
Oh my god.
What are you?
Okay.
What is this?
What is that?
Possible rewards?
What do I get?
Oh, I got a little boy.
I got an exercise commander.
Oh my god, he's sleeping.
Look at him.
That's me.
Oh my god.
That's me again.
Now, I'm shopping a retail therapy for Asuka.
Now, I'm cooking for Asuka.
Okay, that's not... that box wasn't important.
That box...
That box wasn't important.
Okay.
Alright.
Now.
Okay, let's see squad.
Let's see.
Can I upgrade you now?
Okay, I'll just limit break you.
Just limit break you.
That's my best point.
Okay, I limit break her.
I need limit break.
I have so many Neons.
I...
Okay, nice.
Now, you're stronger.
And now, you're a little stronger.
Okay, she should be fine now.
She should be fine, right?
Right.
What was the other one?
Was it honest?
Yeah, it was honest.
Okay.
This should be fine.
We have so many.
Alright.
I'm pretty sure that's all the limit breaks I have.
I know I don't have another Modernia and I don't... I know I don't have another Cinderella.
So, it should be fine.
We should be able to... we can win this now.
Okay, no.
Don't do this to me.
Alright.
This time, we can do this.
I believe.
Oh, wait.
Okay, guys.
I have an idea.
Guys, I have an idea.
What if...
Instead of using these three, I put in these guys.
Like, look at that.
It says... Oh, 3,062.
Like, all I'm saying...
All I'm saying is that...
I could win this.
Okay, we'll try.
We'll see.
Okay, guys.
I think I can win this with this.
I think...
It's all fine.
I have Modernia.
And I have Cinderella, guys.
Okay, but if I put...
If I get rid of these guys and put on these guys...
Oh, it's a lot higher.
Nevermind.
Wait, I think it's... Nevermind.
It's 3,615.
It was a lot higher.
I just couldn't count, guys.
Okay, now I know.
Now I know.
Okay, we're not gonna fuck around.
We're just gonna...
We're not gonna fuck around, guys.
We're gonna do our best.
Okay.
Okay, there we go.
Alright.
Nice, nice.
Okay.
Alright.
It's a lot better!
Guys, this is so much better, guys!
This is actually so much better.
We're doing it, guys.
I told you.
It's all about the limit breaks.
It's all about the limit breaks, guys.
Oh, I messed up.
I messed up.
Oh, no.
It's fine.
It's so fine.
We did it!
I told you.
I told...
Look at that.
You guys didn't believe.
Who would've thought?
Welcome back, Captain.
I'm fine.
That's right, Commander.
Who's she?
We're here now.
There's no need to worry.
Just in time, Seraphine.
Leave it to us to hold down the fort until the helm is fully recovered.
Still immobilized.
One more hit and it's scrap.
Mighty tools haven't arrived yet.
We'll have to make do with the materials gathered nearby.
We'll do what we can.
Like pulling an all-nighter hauling water.
So it's not looking good.
The enemy recovers while we're stalled.
Easy does it.
It's time like these that we need extra patience.
No need to panic.
It's not like the sky's falling.
We've got backup now.
Let's trust them.
Are you done chatting?
Just like we thought.
Fandom's still trying to summon itself into one piece.
We need to stop it as soon as possible!
Things could be out of control.
Are you fine with that?
What kind of stupid question is that?
I'll crush that thing no matter what!
Asuka...
You can't stand idle!
This is Willy's duty too!
Ray, will you fight with us?
If it's an order, I will.
But is it your own will?
Do you want to fight?
I don't know.
Seriously?
Now is not the time to have that talk.
We need your power to return home!
You... need me?
I hate to say this, but we could really use your help.
Yes, it's a team effort!
Team, you said?
Alright, can I actually have them on my team now?
Oh, I have to do this again?
Wait, did I not finish the fight?
Oh my god!
How do they get stronger?
What the...
Oh my god...
Oh, a sage, okay.
Oh god...
Guys, I don't know now.
This is...
This is a lot.
Oh, I got claim.
I obtained 20 points.
Alright.
What are my rewards?
Nice.
And then I get an abnormal daily card.
Nice, okay.
Oh, this is so awkward.
Wait, can I level them now?
This is so awkward for my girl.
Oh, no...
You know what?
Maybe I'll get Asuka.
Maybe I'll get her.
It'll be easier.
Oh, no...
Guys, I can't just play the campaign, guys.
I can't just...
Guys, we can do this.
How broke are you?
Don't judge me!
You can't just ask me how broke I am!
I'm sorry!
Okay, this is fine.
This is fine, this is fine.
We can kill them, I believe.
I'll just use Cinderella.
We'll just use Cinderella.
We'll just...
We'll just do our best.
It's fine.
Okay.
It's fine, it's fine, it's fine, it's fine.
It's so fine.
Oh, it's not fine.
Oh, it's so... It's not fine anymore.
It's not fine anymore, guys.
It's not fine anymore.
No!
Oh, no.
Guys, maybe we can get Asuka.
Guys, no, I can't.
I can't.
Guys, and we're doing campaign.
I'm skipping the story.
Oh, my God, we get Limit Breaker!
Let's go!
We'll Limit Breaker.
We'll just Limit... Guys, it's possible.
I'll just Limit Break.
I'll just...
Okay.
Let me go Limit Breaker real quick.
Oh, she can't be... No, she's maxed!
Guys, and we play campaign.
I'm skipping the story.
Oh, my God.
I'm back here!
Oh, my God!
Okay, we're changing this up.
Okay.
I can read it later.
Guys, I just...
Okay.
It's fine.
Okay, wait.
I don't want to use her.
Let's just use her real fast.
Don't worry, we're so strong.
There's no way.
We're so strong right now.
Look at that.
Everything dies.
Wow, I wish this was...
Guys, what do I have to complete to finish it?
I said...
Okay, guys.
Oh, my God.
Wait, I got upgrades!
Oh, my God!
Wait, how do I do auto?
There's auto?
Oh, my God.
Goodbye.
Oh, it's on auto already.
Oh, my God.
Get me out of the sniper.
Where is she?
Okay, but what if I just upgrade...
Moderna?
Like, is that stupid?
Why would I waste my materials?
I'm like...
Wait.
Oh, wait.
I didn't see it.
What if, like...
What if I just, like...
No, that's actually...
What if, like, I just level up...
Yeah.
I literally just level up Moderna.
I don't level up anybody else.
We just...
We just level her up.
Who cares about the three other characters?
They're purple.
They don't matter.
Yeah, exactly.
Exactly.
I just spend all my upgrades.
I mean, Cinderella is already level 40.
It's fine.
Cinderella is nearly level 40.
So, it's fine.
Oh, wait.
What?
Oh, my God.
Why was I aiming?
What?
I'll never have to...
I'll never aim again.
What?
Oh, my God.
100% accuracy right there.
You mean I never had to aim in the first place?
Oh, my God.
What have I been...
I finally unlocked the shop.
Oh, my God.
The tutorial.
Okay.
Yay, Cinderella.
Oh, my God.
I can upgrade her.
We can upgrade her now?
Oh, my God.
I can.
I just need more cards.
Alright.
There we go.
It's just that easy.
Oh, my God.
Two years of tutorial.
Let's go.
Oh,
my God.
What have I been wasting my time on when I could have literally done this?
Oh, you think I'm done with you?
Come on.
Wait, I don't care about you.
There we go.
Wow, that was so easy.
Yay.
My aimbot going live right now.
Okay.
Do I have enough now?
Okay, I should have enough.
Alright.
I'll figure out your story later.
I'll figure out...
Okay.
There we go.
Yay.
My aimbot's working.
I just...
Guys, you don't understand.
Guys, I'm only doing this for the campaign.
I'll turn the auto off later, guys.
It's just the campaign, guys.
I swear to God.
I swear to God, it's just the campaign.
I just need to get out of here.
I need to get out.
I took too easy.
Guys, I swear to God.
I just want to get out of here.
Oh, you're right.
I should...
Okay, while the game plays for me, give me a sec.
Let me put something on real quick, guys, while the game plays.
Alright.
I'm back, guys.
I gotta play the part.
What's the synchro device?
Thank you, thank you.
Alright, aimbot on.
Oh my God.
As we should be.
Alright.
I need everything.
Oh, I can't really use synchro yet.
I need to finish this tutorial, right?
Go ahead and lock in this tutorial.
I'm gonna use the bathroom.
God, I won?
Oh my God!
Oh, that's crazy!
That's...
Oh my God!
That's crazy!
I won!
Woah, okay.
More balls, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh, wow.
I'm so good.
Doing it.
Look at that!
Not even... look at that.
No hands.
Not even looking at... look at that.
Eyes closed.
Woah!
Oh my God!
Pew, pew, pew, pew, pew.
Look at that.
Oh, there we go.
Real gaming hours.
Send that clip in for gamer of the year.
She's so good!
There we go.
We did it.
Playing with no hands is crazy.
Okay.
Oh, I can equip stuff now.
Quick equip.
Okay.
Oh shit, nice.
Now they all have armor.
Thank God.
Wait, does that mean I can give them armor?
All of them armor?
Oh, I can!
Okay.
I don't have gear for her.
Do I have gear for these guys?
I do.
Okay, that's good.
That's good.
Okay, no.
Okay, it's okay.
We all know who we're focusing all our upgrades on anyway.
Okay, nice.
Level 36.
There we go.
It should be fine now.
We should be okay.
Alright.
Okay.
There we go.
Alright,
let's go.
I believe in us.
I mean, we're so overleveled now.
There we go.
Look at me go.
You know what?
We don't need auto.
Watch this.
Look at that.
Did I win?
Oh my god, I did it.
I literally...
I turned off auto for the final kill.
I was like, wait, what?
I...
Just for the final blow.
I did it.
For the final blow.
I had to kill myself.
All me, by the way.
All me.
I did that.
No one else helped.
No one else was part of it.
Bro stole the kill.
How is this still locked?
Did I not clear 212?
I cleared it!
Wait, where am I?
I did!
Oh, I had to go to the shop.
Oh wait, it's zero dollars.
Yeah, I'll buy that.
Yes, it's zero dollars.
I don't have enough money.
That's a dog.
Who let this dog in?
Wait, I did not finish the chapter?
Chapter confirmed.
Where's the deputy's room?
Oh, there he is.
Who let this dog in?
Give me my room.
You are...
Yay!
It's fine.
Okay, now I have...
Okay, now they live in my house.
Okay, I remember this.
Guys, I don't need...
We don't have to go through this.
I'm my last sponsor.
We already... Oh, I can claim.
Oh my god, yes, claim.
Give me my money.
Nice.
Oh my god, I can upgrade her more.
Guys, wait, the stream doesn't exist anymore.
Wait, we went through these before.
I forgot the stream for...
When I went through...
When I went through this, it doesn't exist anymore.
Okay.
Alright.
Nice.
We did it, guys.
We did it.
We unlocked...
We unlocked the outpost.
We did it.
Now, where are you?
What?
Who are you?
Oh.
You let this child in here.
She's a CEO?
Who let this child become CEO?
I'm getting a cough job.
Oh, I know her!
Is that...
Whoa.
Suddenly, your legs do strength.
Oh, but I skipped.
I didn't like where this was going.
I...
I didn't like where it was going.
But...
No!
Guys, no, no.
No, no, no, no, no.
I did not like where it was heading towards, guys.
I had to skip.
I was not...
I was not feeling that.
I don't skip.
Wait, why can't I use it?
I need complete 3-1!
Okay.
Guys, give me a sec.
Apparently, I need a complete 3-1.
Give me a sec.
I need one more stage.
Let me beat up this one guy real quick, guys.
Let me...
There we go.
What?
Temporary place.
That's a wrap.
Why are these guys here?
I don't want them on my team.
Okay, fine.
My last glimmer of hope.
God, just like that.
AKB.
Hey, if you wanna see that, you can download the game right now using my link in the chat in the description below, guys.
If you wanna see that, you can easily download the game right now, guys.
Come on, I know you guys want to.
It's in the chat in my description right now.
If you wanna know what goes on after Rage 8.
But...
Yeah, but you can replay that moment, guys.
You can download it and make a new account and replay that exact moment.
So you can go through that.
Oh my god, can I finally?
Oh my god.
Oh my god, finally.
I know what I'm gonna do with this.
Alright, Modernia.
This is for you.
Level 40.
Yay!
Oh my god, my attraction rank with her.
Oh my god, I can enhance my bond, but you don't matter to me.
It's all about...
Okay, there we go.
We should be good now.
I'm not wasting it on the others.
All in.
Now we have two level 40s.
If you think I'm gonna waste it on my purpose, you have another thing coming.
Okay.
Alright, this time, we should be fine now.
This is it.
Oh my god, how are we still not fine?
How are we?
Oh my god.
Wait, how do I use?
Oh, fuck.
Okay.
I put the level 200.
Wait, I have a level 200?
Oh my god, you're right.
You don't matter.
There we go.
We should win this, right?
Wait.
Guys, do you think we can win this now?
Guys, I love you dear god.
We don't need bonuses.
We don't need bonuses, guys.
We don't need it.
We don't need bonuses.
Alright, let's see how this goes, guys.
Let's see how this goes.
Oh my god, this game is so easy.
Wow.
This game is awesome.
Woah, yeah!
We won!
Yay, we won!
Let's go!
We won!
Alright.
Nice.
It's so easy.
We did it, guys.
Oh my god.
So much skill.
Oh wait, there he is!
Alright, I wanna look at...
Oh my god, look at him go.
Look at them go.
You know what?
I wanna know what this is like.
With...
What is it like?
Oh, he's just one hit.
Look at my no hands.
Nice.
You don't need all three.
I don't.
It's all about sending a message.
It's literally...
It's about the message!
You think I care?
This is about the message!
It's been on my mind for a while now.
What's that?
Is it for Evangelion?
This is an L Barrier Density Detector.
This red area is extremely dangerous for you all.
What happens if we go in there?
We get launched into the stratosphere or something?
Are you an idiot?
You'll die!
Humans can't operate in the red area without protective gear.
But we're Nikes, so we should be fine, right?
Yeah, they're not humans.
Machines don't work there either.
So Nikes are no exception.
Seriously?
Commander, please be careful.
Would you like to hold my hand?
We never know when...
When danger might strike.
Oh, thank you, Asuka.
I'm good.
I only hold one person's hand and she's right here.
Let's stay alert.
Should you be alert too?
You're human too, after all.
I'm saving myself for someone special.
Subscribe!
Um...
Asuka raises her hand and touches her eyepatch.
Begone, wench!
I'm saving myself for her!
That's a long story.
Let's go.
We have more important things to do.
Sigh.
Does it see this color?
I think I'm gonna lose my sense of direction.
And it looks like...
Ruptures are everywhere.
Zero, thank you for the superchat.
Thank you, thank you.
Crappiest always, NTR.
We're gonna get lost at this rate.
Oh, I found it!
Huh?
It's only for Asuka and Cinderella.
Over there!
I see a huge ship!
Guys, I think the year of snake is not a good gacha year for me.
I look at the direction near points.
Is that...
That wonder?
Why is it here?
Wow!
It's a massive ship!
That's a triple A wonder!
It's Willy's Battleship!
Battleship.
It must have been summoned to this world, like us.
I wonder if the rest of the crew is there too.
Rui tilts her head slightly and looks at the wonder.
It's not damaged.
Oh, you mean the part you blew up?
It's been repaired!
I see.
Can we use it as a power source?
My first...
My firepower ally found this, so it can't be bad.
Sakura, do you think it can help us take down the phantom?
I'm not sure.
Can you get close and check it out?
Sure!
Commander, look!
There's an Evangelion right there!
That's Mark 09.
It's heavily damaged.
Why isn't Evangelion there?
And it's a total wreck!
But I think it can still move somehow.
Commander!
Signs of rapture activity detected nearby.
Let's head inside the ship for now.
Am I bullet helling now?
Am I Hoto-ing?
No wonder it was flying non-stop after it was activated.
But since the rest of the crew wasn't summoned to this world, it looks like it crashed here.
A supersized flying battleship?
It must have incredible firepower.
That's strange.
The internal structure is completely different than before.
It might have been affected when it was summoned to this world.
This structure... it looks similar to our battleship control system.
Commander, we have a problem.
A massive number of raptures are gathering outside.
We'll stop the investigation for now and focus on the raptures.
I have a suggestion.
How about we use the wonder?
With this size, it must have got... okay, never mind.
It must have awesome firepower.
VV, I just got the game and got Asuka first pull.
Thanks for the luck, Doki.
Sorry if I stole yours.
Thank you for the super chat, VV.
I am here to take away all your bad luck, guys.
I am here to take away all your bad luck so you can get Asuka.
It might be difficult to control the ship by ourselves.
Rappi's right.
We need a lot of people to operate the wonder and fight.
We still can't recover a new unit too, but maybe we can do something with Mark09.
Is that an order?
No, it's not an order, but I'd like you to help us.
Guys, you can click the link in the description and pin in the chat to try your luck pulling her.
Okay, if you're done talking, come over here.
What is it?
Mark09's upper body is intact, so we might be able to use the weapons, but her legs are too damaged so it can barely walk, let alone fight.
Maybe a fine way to move Mark09.
I've been wondering, doesn't the wonder's structure look similar to the admirer we talked about earlier?
You're right.
It does look similar.
The admirer's control system is designed to be operated by a small crew.
So you're saying we can operate the wonder by ourselves?
Then it's settled.
Let's attach Mark09 to the bottom.
Mark09 will handle the attack and the wonder will take care of the movement.
Wow, that's a brilliant plan!
You're the best master!
Are you sure that will work?
It's a pretty reckless plan, but still, we don't have any other options so we might as well try.
Lads, thank you for the Akasupa!
Thank you, thank you!
I don't play Nikkei, but I just did a poll on another gacha earlier and I got the new character in just 20 polls, so thank you, Toki!
Thank you for the Akasupa!
Thank you, thank you!
Are you really gonna fly it?
We're about to face unknown firepower!
Let's get ready to protect Asuka Sakura from incoming rapture!
You're all stealing my luck!
Alright, this should be good enough!
Early lot!
What's wrong?
We're deploying!
Alright, it's bullet hell time!
Oh my god, wait, that's cool!
Wait, that's so cool!
Alright, how do we play this?
Okay...
Speed up...
Slow down...
Safe...
Danger?
Oh, we might get hit, okay.
Fuckin' safe danger!
Oh...
Use the healing damage to the enemy.
Will recharge energy once fully charged.
The AT can be used to affect the AT.
Fields vary depending on... Okay, guys, I need to get my other keyboard.
I don't have arrow keys!
Guys...
Give me a sec.
I just realized I don't have arrow keys.
Give me a sec, let me grab my other keyboard.
Oh my god, where is it?
Grab my other keyboard!
I have so many keyboards!
Oh!
Wait, mouse works too?
Oh my god!
Okay!
Okay, I'll just use my mouse.
Okay, thank god.
Because I was like, I don't have arrow keys.
What the fuck do I do?
Liars?
Okay.
Oh wait, okay.
Okay, yeah, this is easy.
Okay.
We're bullet helling.
Okay, there you go.
This is not too bad.
It's not too bad, we're doing it.
We're...
We're doing it right now.
We're doing it.
Oh, this is easy.
No, mouse works is a lot easier, actually.
Actually, yeah, I'd rather use the mouse.
I'm gonna make a...
Wait, this is so easy.
Oh my god, I'm gaming.
I'm actually gaming.
Nice, we got... Oh, now we have a lot of bullets.
Nice.
I don't need to use...
I don't want to use my barrier.
Whoa!
I'm not using my barrier yet, though.
Nice.
Wait, I did it.
Is that it?
Oh, that was it.
Oh, nice.
Air, air.
Air aligns rings throughout the ship.
Octus ruptures, what do they do to the wonder?
At this rate, the battleship will lose power and crash.
Arm damage detected.
Looks like this is as far as the early lock goes.
The engine, destroyed by the raptors, finally stops roaring.
Black smoke fills the tilting ship.
Sir, get the life jackets!
We're jumping out with parachutes!
Get on!
The passage is clear!
Asuka, Sakura, go first!
Let's go, Sakura.
Commander, you go first!
Okay.
Look, I'm human, I should go first.
The entry plug rejects from the neck of the fallen Mark 09.
She got out!
As Neon, let's go!
Reppy shouts and grabs my waist.
Whoa!
Runs outside.
Whoa.
We land safely in shallow water.
Splash.
I don't think, like, safely would work with shallow water.
I don't think it'd be swimming again.
Commander, are you okay?
I was holding him tight, so he's fine.
I swallowed some seawater.
I'll be okay, right?
You're not even human.
Yes, of course you'll be okay.
Captain, everyone, are you all right?
Is anyone hurt?
Master Pepper!
I knew it was the captain.
Meanwhile, the wonder, shaking in the air, crashes into the sea, creating a massive red wave.
Everyone, get on the lifeboat!
Raptors are right on our heels!
Everyone's still... Okay, we don't care about them yet.
Oh, wait, they're here.
We always cared about you.
Appeared from the side.
Me?
We're safe.
That's a relief.
Hurry up and get on.
But the wonder...
Don't worry.
It won't sink easily.
Let's hop on the boat for now.
I've always cared, guys.
I've always cared.
I see.
By the way, you fought while piling that massive...
Whoa, money.
That's incredible.
Someone get her a towel!
She has been wet this entire story.
Okay, come help us next time.
Oh my God, someone please get her a towel before she gets a cold.
Is there something wrong?
Thanks.
What are you talking about?
You're the one who did all the heavy lifting.
Yeah, but we helped each other.
She's the anchor.
What does that mean?
Do they just throw her off the ship when they need an anchor?
It's been ages since I've been here.
It seems like something really huge just happened.
Watching the world of those cute Nikkis get destroyed like this, I can't just stand by and do nothing.
Wait, what?
Really?
What?
Wait, did they actually just throw her off the fucking boat if they need an anchor?
That's crazy.
That's actually crazy.
Wait, can I actually play the minigame now?
Can we get back to the part where we got stepped on?
No.
If you want to see it out of context, you can easily
download the game yourself and get to that area.
Okay, I want to upgrade extra weapon, armor part.
Wait, can I even upgrade anything?
I don't even think I can.
I'm broke as hell.
Oh wait, I can.
Nice.
Alright.
What is this?
Okay, let's actually start the real minigame then.
Alright, let's do another level and then we will call it here.
This is so easy though.
I didn't even have to use my armor thing.
I think I'm just a naturally god gamer.
What can I say?
I'm just that good.
Look at that.
I just shoot everywhere now.
Nice.
Pew, pew, pew, pew.
Oh wait, what happened to my thing?
Okay.
I shouldn't move too fast.
Okay, nice.
Got more bullets.
Some little bit more bullets.
Right here.
Nice.
Then we gotta get rid of him.
Oh my god, he is so strong.
How do I...
Oh no, that's not what I wanted!
Press space!
God damn it.
I didn't want to press space there.
Alright.
Yay!
I did it.
Oh nice, I have a new weapon too.
Alright, I think that...
I think I looked through everything.
Yeah!
Oh my god.
That was fun though.
That was really fun.
I can't believe I spent money on my first gacha game.
On EK.
I can't believe it.
I can't believe I spent money on my first gacha game.
The very first time I've ever spent money.
That's actually crazy for me.
I can't even get you.
I don't even have money.
I need 200.
Oh my god.
Do I have anything that I can claim that will give me 270?
Guys, is there anything else I can claim?
Do I have any more free stuff?
I must have.
Wait.
Wait, I have one more pull.
Wait, guys.
Guys, I have one more pull.
Oh my god.
This could be it.
This was not it.
It's alright.
It was so...
It was fun.
Thank you again, Nikkei, for...
Thank you, Nikkei, for sponsoring me.
I had a great time though.
Honestly, like, it was honestly a great time today.
You know, this was supposed to be an hour stream, but like, obviously, I had such a great time that it didn't turn into an hour.
Yeah, we've been playing for a while now.
Oh my god, we were playing for two hours.
It's okay.
It's like she's here.
It's like she's here with me right now.
It's like, oh my god.
Oh my god, Willi.
It's like you're here right now, Willi.
Look at that.
It's like I'm playing you right now.
Right now.
Oh, she's so cute.
Look at her.
Looks like she's about to murder you.
It's like I'm playing her right now.
Good on me, Gabe.
Look at that.
Worst met you while standing.
Wait, what?
Oh.
It's like, oh, they're like Japanese voice acting.
Oh, I guess.
Well, I can't even get her anyway, so it doesn't even matter.
She's like normal gun.
What about...
Okay.
Asuka, Marie, but like nobody.
It's so funny.
It's so funny that um...
that like we went straight to like Sakura.
But yeah, it was fun though.
I had a great time.
I can't believe I got Asuka like four times, guys.
See?
Asuka one, Asuka two, Asuka three.
Where's my fourth Asuka?
I know I got a fourth one.
Asuka four, Asuka five.
Wow, so many.
So many Asukas.
Alright, oh my god.
What do I do to deserve all of you?
Oh my god.
You were all here.
Oh, so many of you were here.
Wait, how do I...
How do I change my...
How do I change her?
I have a new girl.
I don't want her.
That sounds so sad.
Guys, how do I change her?
Top right.
Liar.
Lobby.
Oh, okay.
Okay, get out.
Sorry, wait.
How do I get you out of here?
Okay, there you go.
Nope.
Cinderella, Moderna, Cinderella.
Where's my Asuka army?
Asuka, Asuka, Asuka.
Hahaha.
My family of Asuka.
Whoa, okay.
Oh my god, okay.
And then Asuka number two.
Oh, Boo Crow?
You're right, you're right.
Let me replace Crow with Asuka number...
Where's my other Asuka?
Don't worry, I have plenty of Asuka.
There you go.
There's my other Asuka right there.
And then Asuka number three.
And then Asuka number four.
Don't worry, sorry guys, sorry.
I forgot one important thing.
Asuka number four.
Hahaha.
Asuka number five.
Oh my god.
Asuka, I'm so happy.
Oh my god, look at all my Asukas.
Oh my god.
You're all so beautiful, Asuka.
You're all so beautiful.
Oh my god.
Hahaha.
I'm so blessed.
Anyway guys, oh shit, whoops.
Thank you all for coming, everybody.
As always, everyone, I hope you guys, please check out the game.
Like I said, check out the game in the description below and click on the link in the description below or pinned on the chat.
Thank you again to Nikkei for the sponsor.
Please download the game and support me or the stream.
As always, everybody, stay hydrated, posture check, get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
If you stayed up for me, head to bed cause you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time everybody.
Bye guys.
Bye.